[موسيقى]
اتهامات جديده تواجه رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو يرى زعيم
المعارضه يا ايرلابيد ان ادعاء نتنياهو
اصدار تعليمات لرئيس الاركان بالحفاظ على
كفاءه واستعداد الجيش الاسرائيلي ليست سوى
محاوله مخزيه وجبنه للتهرب من المسؤوليه
حسب تعبيره هجوم لابيت تزامن مع الالغاء
نتنياهو عطله مخططه له في الجولان المحتل
ودعوته الاجتماع وزير الدفاع
وقياده الجيش الاسرائيلي لقاء قال عنه
مكتب نتنياهو انه روتيني وان جميع
المشاركين في المحادثات اتفقوا على ضروره
ترك الخلافه السياسيه خارج الجيش
الاسرائيلي الجدل المستمر ياتي على خلفيه
رفض جنود وضباط بينهم طيارون الالتحاق
بالتجنيد الطوعي على خلفيه التغييرات
القضائيه ولا تزال النسبه منخفضه جدا لكن
لحراكها رمزيه كبرى تنقسم هيكليه الجيش
الاسرائيلي الى الجيش النظامي وقوات
الاحتياط والقوات الخاصه وتعد قوات
الاحتياط في الجيش العمود الفقري في اوقات
الطوارئ التي تعيش اسرائيل في ظلها غالبيه
الوقت ويناط بها تنفيذ مختلف المهام
الامنيه والعسكريه ويتكون الاحتياط من
الجنود الذين ادوا الخدمه العسكريه
الاجباريه لمن يبلغون السن القانونيه ويتم
استدعائهم سنويا لدورات تدريبيه وبعد
الانتهاء من الخدمه الالزاميه يتحول
الجنود تلقائيا الى قوات الاحتياط وهي
تشكل غالبيه تعداد القوات المسلحه
[موسيقى]